[Applaudissements]
c'est un gros gars là mais c'est un bon
gars là niveau national voilà il ya des
gens qui viennent de bretagne du nord de
la france enfin un peu partout de la
france dans la france pour rencontrer
les boxeurs dire du 78 et à dix boxeurs
du club de chez nous plus des boxeurs
que ça sonne marly-le-roi les mureaux
enfin un peu partout du son et la
verrière un peu partout du 78 qui
viendront aussi affronter les boxeurs de
2 d'ailleurs quoi voilà de la france
ça permet aux boxeurs de progresser de
se faire un nom aussi parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de la cedh et de mots il ya
beaucoup de nouveaux qui vont commencer
et certains qui vont sûrement passer pro
d'ici un an voilà un an voire deux ans
ils vont commencer à faire leurs armes
comme ibrahim fofana liesse et ja oui
voilà il y en a un petit jeune là
qu'arrive de montigny-le-bretonneux qui
mathias voilà beau train qui vient de
commencer il a déjà huit combats six
victoires et je pense que c'est sur mon
avenir
c'est grave ça nous manque bien sûr là
et là on est un peu dans l'inconnu comme
je dis il ya beaucoup de des gens qui
vont faire leur premier combat du club
mais oui oui c'est ça fait plaisir c'est
vraiment ça fait plaisir on va retrouver
les lettres de noblesse d'ici voilà le
prochain gala on retrouvera les vrais il
devrait boxer comme on a chez nous
[Applaudissements]